Les vendeurs ou les vendeuses dans les magasins, moi je trouve que vraiment..
John Rachid : FAUX !
Heu .. attends j'ai encore rien dit là , moi j'aime bien les vendeurs dans les boutiques ou les magasins,
c'est un métier pas évident et ils sont toujours là pour nous aider nous conseiller et parfois même nous faire
CRACHER NOTRE THUNE !! Il y a aussi ce vendeur très malin pour te vendre un produit il est super sympa avec toi,
il est cool, il fait des blagues, à la limite le temps d'une vente ça devient ton meilleur pote, quoi
*Générique De Friends*
Hugo (Vendeur) : "Au revoir."
Norman : "Ouais mais non, on avait dit.. " Hugo (Vendeur) : "AU REVOIR."
et pour les vacances, qu'on devait faire
Hugo (vendeur): Tu te casses maintenant j'ai du taf là ! Ouais allô ?
ouais tu peux aller me chercher en réserve de boîtes
Norman : on devait faire un Fifa ...  Vendeur : Bon tu te casses maintenant !!!
En plus franchement je sais pas vous mais moi je pense pas être un client chiant hein... Si par exemple dans une boutique
de vêtements je replie pas un t-shirt après l'avoir essayé c'est juste parce que je sais pas plier un t-shirt aussi bien que les vendeurs
Pliage de CP ! Norman: Excusez moi vous pouvez plier mon linge de chez moi ?
Hugo (vendeur) : Non.
Norman: Allez !
Hugo (vendeur): Non.
Norman : allez...
Hugo (Vendeur): D'accord.
Norman: Les vendeurs de vêtements, ils sont là pour te donner des p'tits conseils sur ce que tu veux acheter.
Et moi j'aime pas trop parce que en même temps, il juge tes goûts, tsais...
Hugo (Vendeur): Ah non, Ouais, mais ça va pas du tout.
Non ça vous grossit, ça va pas à votre teint, c'est pas pour vous ça monsieur
Norman : Non en fait c'est mon pull à moi ça. Hugo (Vendeur) : Ah pardon , et bah il est super bien ...suivant. (Un jean tombe sur la tête du vendeur)
Norman: Et puis moi j'aime pas les cabines d'essayage , dès que tu tires le rideau d'un côté ça s'ouvre de l'autre côté...
*Rideau qui bouge*
Il est cassé...
Bref au final  il y a toujours une petite fente bien gênante où les gens peuvent te voir à poil...
Et puis en plus j'sais pas si ça vous le fait.
Mais moi quand j'ai demandé au vendeur d'essayer dix mille produits et que finalement je prends rien.
C'est con mais je culpabilise
Vendeur  (HUGO) :alors vous en pensez quoi de cette quinzième paire ?
(hésite)
Norman: J'aime pas trop en fait... Je la prends pas...
hum...
Musique triste.
Vendeur : Bon bah ... c'est pas grave je vais.
Ranger toutes ces paires tout seul, et puis je vais dire mon patron que j'ai fait zéro vente, et il va me virer... et...
puis je vais me faire quitter par ma femme quoi...
Norman: Ok,ok , je vais prendre un porte-clé, pointure 1.
Quand il y a trop de monde dans le magasin le vendeur est déjà occupé avec plein de clients
et toi tu dois attendre ton tour, en le suivant partout comme un chien chien
*benny theme*
A ce moment là le vendeur il est tellement sollicité,
limite il se prend un peu pour une star quoi... Star: Donc ici vous avez le rayon slip, il y a toutes les tailles...
Ouais j'ai d'abord ce client là, chacun son tour d'accord ?
Pas de flash , je vous remercie.
Client : Pour Killian pour Killian  : j'attends votre rayon j'ai suivi toutes vos ventes. Star: J'te remercie.
bon les filles qui veut une Dedi-boobs ? Fans : Moi moi moi moi ... |Coach Norman : est-ce que vous avez des questions |Client : vous avez la pointure 45 | Coach Norman : je vais voir en stock | Fans : *cris*
Merci Carrefour vous avez été énormes
on se revoit demain je serai là à 9h  : PARCE QUE C'EST NOTRE PROJEEEEETTTT !!!!!!
En tout cas ce qui est sûr c'est que je préfère un vendeur qui n'a pas la réponse à ce que je demande, plutôt que ce vendeur qui
fait style de le savoir mais qui en fait découvre le produit en même temps que toi. Vendeur (Norman) : alors la consommation d'énergie plutôt faible.
Elle a un mode veille, et elle et 4K Full HD, Full HD.
Client : Ok, je crois que vous lisez vraiment la fiche d'un autre produit.
Vendeur : Non , un deux et là c'est canal+... Norman : et parfois même limite tu connais mieux le produit que lui |Client : alors vous avez le mode grill, décongélation
micro-ondes énergie à peu près 600 watts voilà... Vendeur (norman)  : C'est génial, je peux payer en plusieurs fois ? Client (hugo) : Bien sûr. Vendeur(norman) : Yes,
je le prends direct... Norman : Ça me saoule quand les vendeurs veulent te refourguer une garantie
t'sais, ils dramatisent tout pour que tu flippes et que tu la prennes. Vendeur : est ce que vous prenez la garantie ? Client : Non c'est bon merci. Vendeur : Dommage.
Peut-être que dans dix ans votre télé va tomber en panne à cause d'un incendie dans votre foyer
Et peut-être même d'inondations
Peut-être que la foudre va tomber sur votre famille et tuer vos enfants... |Client : C'est bon, stop,stop je veux pas de garantie je veux pas de garantie c'est bon...
Ok...
*Norman balance la télévision qui coûte ultra cher*
Voilà pas de garantie...
Mais les plus forts que j'ai connus dans ma vie ça reste quand même les vendeurs d'instruments de musique.
Alors eux ils savent vraiment comment te donner envie d'acheter, tout en te faisant passer pour une petite merde...
*Son De Guitare Un Peu Nul*
Je crois qu'elle est pas accordée je sais pas si euh ... Vendeur : Ah bon ? Faites voir ?
*Son de Guitare Électrique Qui Déchire*
Ouais non mais j'vais pas la prendre en fait...
Je vais plutôt prendre des cours de guitare... En tout cas j'encourage tous mes potos vendeurs et vendeuses, parce qu'ils font un métier pas évident
surtout qu'ils doivent tomber sur beaucoup de clients bien relous. Alors promis dorénavant on va tous essayer d'être des clients exemplaires, mais juste un truc...
Comment on plie un t-shirt ?
C'est quoi, c'est... c'est le nœud de chaise. Au fait vous êtes bientôt 10 millions d'abonnés à ma chaîne youtube, c'est un truc de OUF !
C'est un cap historique de ma vie, donc continuez à vous abonner c'est maintenant ou jamais, et je lance au slogan officiel...
Que j'ai inventé de moi même c'est tout simplement: (accent anglais pas ouf) "Go to 10 millions..." Voilà c'est pas ouf mais....
Mais j'ai mis un mois...
Abonnez-vous a la chaîne de NormanFaitDesVidéos, il faut que vous soyez 10 millions, ça sera le deuxième Youtubeur en France à avoir 10 millions d'abonnés, après Cyprien ! Signé, l'équipe de Traduction.